vous savez qu'on peut tous faire
implanter pour ceux qui font pas de
sport par exemple autour de la table
parce que tout à l'heure je peux le dire
je me dis que je vais pas pour faire du
sport avec oui mais je n'aurai que j'ai
proposé ne veut pas bah oui mais battu
très bien une étude a franchement il ya
un accord y perd correct on en a
vraiment
j'la développement sortir courant mais
c'est pour les spectateurs pourquoi tu
m'as vu torse nu parce que bas parce qu
on se change dans la même loge
oui voilà il aime ça qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui s'il avec un sou les bonnes
choses que là c'est parce que ça crée
des liens c'était des pierres
on l'avait bien mérité après l'émission
se change tout dans la loge il m'a
proposé de me laver au gant et les
sources malgré ce qu'il se passe en loge
mon dieu donc et donc je distingue au
dollar à planter des pecs des avant-bras
des biceps des tris est donc toujours
chez vous mais ça sert à quoi parce que
si tu as dis ça et tu peux rien porter
parce que t'as pas nous c'est ce que
c'est un peu quatre de leurs mots ce
qu'il avait perdu contre un bras de fer
je les paie contrats qu'elle juge encore
bombe avec ses kenji et aussi rimer
mokhtar où vas tu faire
non là c'est quand avec tout le respect
que j'ai pour cali dit que j'embrasse et
que j'aime beaucoup c'est un débat en
dehors de ça vous avez vous tapez moctar
ben moctar a les bonnes habitudes ne
propose pas d'aller faire du sport on
fait moins le malin de leurs noms mais
habile et pourquoi pas jean lui parce
que c'est mieux comme ça un peu jean luc
y attention
déjà la malle fait trois feux n'éclate
moi ce gars a nommé allez-vous légaux en
coulisses il a insulté
ouais et insulté sa mère
et
comment les pompiers cours de l'an
laurent
on est venu prochain alors justement
c'est petit voyage pour aller au bout de
l'information tu les as fait implanter
ou
jean nougaret lukasz urban est loué
c'est un petit bras direct de lancer
quelqu'un pointe de la battue c'est à
laisser partir
suppl isabelle mon amour mais vraiment
des frac tenable delormeau a menacé de
bryan avait annoncé qu'elle manque
d'élégance et a vu des andes des hommes
qui vieillissent et qui sont fait faire
des implants avec les plis qui repose
sur les âmes plantes non ça te regarde
voilà on a entendu les tirs et mon âge
on n'a pas tout compris mais c'était
bien parce que les implants dentaires se
fixe comme jean-marie baudoin l'a
vraiment aller ségala l'onema pref gouv
et allez-y
il
jean-louis les méchants on va le
retrouver dans un instant le méfiant
fiel très très méchant de leurs rêves